razzia im kanzleramt in berlin schwere
vorwürfe gegen österreichs kanzler
sebastian kurz am mittwoch rückten
fahnder an um im kanzleramt in der
övp-zentrale im finanzministerium und in
einem medienhaus materialien zu sichern
sie suchten mails aus der zeit seit
anfang 2016 sowie datenträger server
handys und laptops betroffen war der
engste kreis um kurz etwa sein
pressesprecher seinen medienberater und
sein chefstratege
kurz und sein team stehen im verdacht
sich wohl meine berichterstattung in
einem medienunternehmen erkauft zu haben
um sebastian kurz den weg an die
parteispitze und in das bundeskanzleramt
zu ebnen er heftige vorwürfe jetzt hat
sich österreichs bundeskanzler zu den
schweren korruptionsvorwürfen gegen ihn
und sein team selbst geäußert dazu ist
jetzt unser bild vize paul ronzheimer in
wien zugeschaltet
paul ja was hat sebastian kurz denn
gesagt
sebastian kurz hat alle vorwürfe
zurückgewiesen er hat gesagt es könne
nicht sein dass er hier für alles
verantwortlich gemacht werden soll er
hat sich bereits in der zib2 der
bekanntesten nachrichtensendung des
landes geäußert am tag als die vorwürfe
hochkamen jetzt gab es in den
vergangenen tagen gespräche immer wieder
mit dem bundespräsident nun vor allem
aber auch mit seinem koalitionspartner
den grünen und diese grüne die sind für
sebastian kurz jetzt das größte problem
in der frage ob er an der macht bleiben
kann denn sie haben sich sehr eindeutig
geäußert sie haben mehr oder weniger
klar gesagt dass es so nicht weitergehen
kann in dieser koalition mit den
vorwürfen denn ist es so dass ist ja
bereits vorwürfe gab vor ein paar
monaten damals ging es um eine
falschaussage auch das hochgekommen
durch eine handy eines ehemaligen
vertrauten da gab es tausende
textnachrichten die sichergestellt
wurden von der staatsanwaltschaft und da
kommt immer wieder neues hoch immer
wieder neue vorwürfe und die grünen so
scheint ist sie haben davon jetzt die
nase voll und es ist mit spannung zu
sehen was hier in den nächsten tagen
passiert ich gehe davon aus dass
sebastian kurz als österreichischer
kanzler am dienstag stürzen könnte dass
es eine abwahl gibt hier im parlament
einen misstrauensantrag
gestellt worden und es könnte so sein
dass die grünen dann für das vorzeitige
ende von sebastian kurz sorgen werden
und das wäre bereits das zweite mal denn
wir erinnern uns vor zwei jahren in der
ibiza affäre als heinz christian strache
gestürzt wurde über dieses video oder
gefallen ist über dieses video dann gab
es sozusagen auch die aufforderung an
sebastian kurz zu gehen da gab es den
misstrauensantrag im parlament und
damals wurde er schon einmal abgewählt
paul ronzheimer rechnen mit einem sturz
des österreichischen kanzlers auch paul
das interview angesprochen das was ja
ein kurzer zeit im bild gegeben hat wir
wollen da einmal gemeinsam reinschauen
zunächst einmal es ist überhaupt kein
vergehen sich mit journalisten
pressesprechern
meinungsforschungsinstituten über
umfragen auszutauschen das findet
täglich statt also dass ich informiert
wurde vor fünf jahren über ein
umfrageergebnis vorab das ist alles
andere als glaube ich strafrechtlich
relevant die sms die sie zitieren die
habe ich weder geschrieben noch naharija
pressesprecher mein jetziger
pressesprecher der damals pressesprecher
des finanzamt eine ihrer engsten daraus
konstruieren sie jetzt was einen
strafrechtlichen vorwurf und nein die
frage war er hat sich ihr team diese
umfrage bestellt hat sich ihr team diese
umfrage bei österreich gewünscht
selbstverständlich nicht aber ich bitte
sie um verständnis dass es überhaupt
kein indiz dafür gibt dass ich gesteuert
habe welche inserate oder umfragen im
finanzministerium dann sprechen darüber
ehrlich gesagt nach fünf jahren ist
nicht leicht jedes detail zurück es ist
also alles kann ihnen ich kann ihnen
gern was dazu sagen glaube sie einmal
absolut angebracht aufzuklären ob es
überhaupt irgendeine form der
scheinrechnungen falschabrechnungen oder
sonst irgendetwas gegeben hat und bei
einem respekt der tür ich glaube nicht
dass es das gegeben haben heute fragen
weiß ganz konkret wussten sie von einer
gegenleistung ich finde es spannend dass
jetzt nicht mehr einfach miteinander und
ich kann selbstverständlich mit nein
antworten höhe bleiben sie ganz
selbstverständlich und trotzdem sehe ich
sehr gelassen entgegen
und dieser diskussion stelle ich mich
gerne in jedem detail denn das ich nicht
nachvollziehen kann ist warum an jedem
unrecht immer ich schuld sind in die
mangel genommen vom orf paul sebastian
kurz ist ja sehr beliebt im land als
bundeskanzler wie reagieren denn die
österreicher auf diese vorwürfe
man muss eines klar sagen wenn man sich
die umfragen anschaut dann ist sebastian
kurz weiterhin der beliebteste politiker
im land und darauf stützt sich auf seine
macht wir haben in den vergangenen
stunden in den vergangenen tagen erlebt
wie sich seine gesamte vp die an den
vergangenen jahren umgebaut hat
sozusagen auf ihn fokussiert hat hinter
sich gestellt hat alle landeshauptleute
vergleichbar mit ministerpräsidenten in
deutschland stehen hinter sebastian kurz
genauso wie die minister im kabinett und
die grünen hatten offenbar gehofft dass
sie durch diese aussagen dass sie
abrücken 5 sebastian kurz vielleicht
eine welle in bewegung setzen würden
gegen ihn weil man muss eines klar sagen
diese vorwürfe wiegen schwer nur das
problem für sebastian kurz aber auch für
seine politischen gegner ist dass man
diese vorwürfe in den nächsten wochen in
den nächsten monaten womöglich sogar
auch im nächsten jahr nicht aufklären
wird die ermittlung werden andauern das
wird weitergehen möglicherweise kommen
weitere nachrichten aus diesem handy
hoch da sind ja zehntausende
hunderttausende nachrichten
sichergestellt worden und das ist das
ganz große problem hier in österreich
und man kann sagen das land ist ein
bisschen gespalten auf der einen seite
stehen diejenigen die sagen es reicht
jetzt wirklich diese vorwürfe die kurz
betreffen sein engstes umfeld die
korruption die da im raum steht das muss
jetzt ein ende haben er muss weg es gab
gestern hier tausende menschen die vor
dem kanzleramt wo ich jetzt stehe
demonstriert haben allerdings ist es so
dass es auch eine andere hälfte gibt die
es vor allem nicht hier in wien zu hause
dies vor allem im ländlichen österreich
zu hause und die spricht teilweise immer
noch auch von einer intrige gegen den
kanzler also wenn es tatsächlich in der
nächsten woche eine abwahl geben könnte
einen sturz von sebastian kurz dann so
sagen alle beobachter so höre ich auch
aus dem kanzleramt dann wird er wieder
antreten wollen zu einer wahl und dann
wird er versuchen erneut hier platz 1 zu
erreichen und dann ist die frage wie
soll es hier im land weitergehen und bis
dahin und das ist eine frage und das
auch druck auf den grünen jetzt denn
wenn sebastian kurz gestürzt würde dann
gäbe es eine mehrheit nur mit der
rechtspopulistischen fpö dann wären spd
grüner neos vergleichbar mit der fdp und
der fpö
die rechtspopulisten die einst über die
ibc affäre mit heinz christian strache
gestolpert sind die wären plötzlich
zurück im boot und das wäre ja schon
absurd in der geschichte dieses landes
in der geschichte auch von ibiza dass
dann plötzlich die fpö möglicherweise
mit den grünen gemeinsame sache würde
also ganz ganz viele offene fragen und
eine riesen spannung im land hier in der
hauptstadt in wien was hier in den
nächsten stunden in den nächsten tagen
passieren wird spannende tage für
österreich paul du kennst sebastian kurz
auch persönlich wie geht er mit solch
einer krise jetzt um
ist ein wahnsinniger druck der auf
sebastian kurz lastet in diesen tagen er
hatte sich gerade erst erholt von den
vorwürfen die es gegen ihn gab da ging
es um falschaussage wir erinnern uns er
hat vor einem u ausschuss ausgesagt da
ging es darum ob er von der bestellung
von thomas schmid seinem engsten
vertrauten damals wusste und diese
nachrichten die dann aufgetaucht sind
die zeichnet
ja ja ja ja ja ja okay jetzt man sieht
hier sozusagen auch aufregung
zu diese bastian kurz die stimmung ist
aufgeladen aber du siehst man erkennt
und so offenbar auch irgendwie
es gibt natürlich leute die sebastian
kurz stürzen sehen wollen davon gibt es
einige gerade hier in wien und wir haben
gerade diesen jungen mann gesehen der
gerade das möchte dass sebastian kurz
hier stürzt und es gibt irgendwie ich
erwähnt habe eben auch eine andere seite
hier in österreich und wenn wir jetzt
auch sebastian kurz zu sprechen kommen
noch einmal es gab bereits vorwürfe was
falsch aussagen angeht jetzt gibt es
diese neuen vorwürfe die grünen haben
bei den ersten vorwürfen immer noch so
zu sagen ja
die miene zum bösen spiel gemacht haben
gesagt okay wir machen erstmal weiter
aber jetzt schien es ihnen genug auch
weil der druck in der basis zu groß ist
der basis druck der grünen zu sagen dass
man etwas da jetzt tun muss dass man
nicht länger an der koalition bleiben
kann und das ist die frage wie sebastian
kurz er weitermacht ist scheint für mich
so als wird er versuchen auch nach einer
möglichen abwahl die nächste woche
passieren kann eben an der svp spitze zu
bleiben und dann druck zu machen und
dann in eine richtung neuwahl zu gehen
aber das ist natürlich höchst
kompliziert er hat schon einmal genau
das gleiche durchgemacht damals stand
nicht eher im fokus sondern die erfüllen
mit heinz christian strache und dann hat
er sozusagen nachdem die fpö raus ist
aus der koalition musste er in die
opposition es gab eine
übergangsregierung und dann hat er sich
zurückgekämpft mit einem herausragenden
ergebnis ob er das nochmal schaffen wird
also ob er dann sozusagen als jemand
gegen den as ermittlungen gibt im
wahlkampf bestehen kann das ist die
offene frage
[Musik]